Maria from Brazil
Scott in Louisiana near Baton Rouge
Toronto's
John Toronto
Divine year in the Philippines yep
this is a kind of a program that Appeals
worldwide because
AI is such an important
part of our lives and
it's going to affect us globally so
glad to see people are joining from all
corners of the world
so
starting in just 30 cents here
and when we do get started if you have
questions for Eric
please place them into the Q a of the
zoom chat or the not the zoom chat the
zoom q a
chat will sometimes get a little crowded
and it's much easier for us to find the
questions when they're in the Q a so
see it's time for us to begin so
in our presentation and introduce Eric
and welcome
to this session on why you need AI for
decision making for business strategies
and applications and my name is Stuart
Creek I am with simply learn we are a
delivery partner with Wharton online
for this program
here
with Eric hamburger and who I'll
introduce in a moment
and
we're going to be asking some questions
about you along the way toward the end
We'll be asking some poll questions so
an eye out for those
what we're talking today about the role
of AI in business
why people at the senior levels of
management and the Executive Suite
c-suite need to understand the
technology and how it will impact
their organizations then we'll talk
about what this particular program
offers and how it helps to get you
Future Ready
and I'll share with you information
about enrollment including a bonus offer
that you received
so welcome Eric
um
it's just as a brief two bullet
introduction of you as the managing
director of Wharton online the founding
director of warden live I'd like to tell
people a bit more about yourself please
go right ahead
sure thanks Stuart and welcome everybody
appreciate you carving out time in your
day whether that's the evening the early
morning or wherever we might find you
here today
um
these things are always
you've ever put your intro on a slide
right it can be a little uh embarrassing
of sorts so I am the the founding
managing director of Wharton live which
was a new business Enterprise here at
the Wharton School aimed at bringing
um synchronous virtual programs at scale
and I've been doing that for the last
couple of years the last time Stewart
hosted one of these sessions was with my
longtime colleague and
um kind of Wharton Legend Don huesman
who just retired a few months back
um and I had the opportunity to work
with Don for the last couple of years
and have taken over his status working
online we've combined some teams but
prior to that I was the assistant Dean
um of graduate business at a
Philadelphia College nearby here to Penn
and I've really been in online education
for the last 20 years I teach online
programs myself as an Adjunct professor
I should clarify I don't teach in this
program but I do oversee the entirety of
the Wharton online team and that
includes the production and facilitation
of this program and also our
relationship with simply learn so
you know a little bit of I think
background on on Wharton online as a
business unit and as sort of a
institutional Cornerstone here at the
Wharton School is that you know probably
about 15 years ago give or take our
Provost had asked that we get into the
mooc space
and we helped facilitate that but a lot
has changed since those early days of
math of open online courses and you know
we've Diversified our online offerings
half the standing faculty at the Wharton
School have taught and Wharton online
programs and we're really excited to
bring to bear some of our heaviest
bidders in this program in particular I
think we've got seven at last count and
you can see those in the program bro
store which I'm sure many of you have
taken a look at
um this program itself how to make sense
of AI
as both the resource to manage say the
general manager of a business and also
as an opportunity to guide your
organization kind of around
and across the learning curve into what
is emerging as a new set of technologies
that are augmenting our decision-making
process
so when we think about data driving the
economy you see here on the screen in
front of you what we've been suggesting
is that
AI is such a fast-moving field that
organizations need to take sort of a
portfolio approach to build capacity all
right build capacity within your
organization to use data in their
structured forms
and to experiment with AI to analyze the
unstructured data okay
data that grows and accumulates amongst
our respective data houses eighty
percent of which approximately speaking
of course is unstructured so AI
essentially enables us to mine that data
in search of the gold that's really
varied there right and these
Technologies allow us to test the
hypotheses of our business
and also to manage in uncertain
environments which I would Hazard
against many if not all of us are
operating in right now
and emerging from covid things like
Global conflicts fear of recession
so many other factors
largely of which we have little to no
control over still influence our
deliberative process when it comes to
decision making
whatever we can do to bring data to
better test these hypotheses and the
decision-making options that sit before
us the better the decisions that we make
will ultimately be so when I think about
a chart that Stuart and I have taken a
peek at um which I think is on the next
screen here is produced by McKinsey TTS
has also produced an iteration
um
creating these kind of analyzes they
call for people that sort of stand
between the business models that have
been developed and leveraged by the the
administrative leaders the in and around
the c-suite
and data scientists on the other side
this program in particular
is something that's not intended to be
say engineering and focus instead it
provides this sort of central column
that you see here in the middle of the
screen think broadly about General
management for example which in one
respect is why this program I think has
such blanket appeal and why we've got
such a diverse audience geographically
speaking that we already established
that through the exploration of both
structured and unstructured data you can
literally translate that information
that is coming out of our data
warehouses into a forecast for a
decision-making model that helps inform
the decision-making process across
multiple levels of
what we might call the management
ecosystem of your organization okay
really if you
think about where you are today in
contrast to where you will be in
completion of this program
picturing yourself is understanding
enough about Ai and machine learning
technologies that are currently maturing
before our very eyes and then sort of
apply that understanding and Advising
senior leadership at your organization
to form questions that data can help us
answer all right so it's really that mid
to senior level role that will analyze
cases covering companies at the Leading
Edge of extracting critical information
from the loose data available to them
amongst the vast repositories of
unstructured data that are out there
that's some of the things that you'll be
taking a look at in this program with
our faculty
and I should say that in that pool of
unstructured data we're talking about I
don't know email voicemail video Audio
Web purchasing traffic
um this these things inform customer
profiles right and they reveal how we're
sort of
customers are exploring and ultimately
finding their way to make a purchase
all of these data sources are frankly
different than when I don't know I think
about myself as a young consumer say 20
years ago when we only had things like
tabular data right think relational
databases like spreadsheets that were
organized by rows and by columns right
that were applied to more sort of direct
ways to predict and drive forecasting
models that were frankly in a world of
far more uncertainty
back then we did things like scenario
planning sensitivity analyzes now and
what we talk about in part in this
program is kind of the optimization of
models that emerge with Clear Choices
and expected forecasts
in the old days of relational like
database Management systems and these
various forms of structured data
um
I mean this this isn't our parents
course though really right this is a new
day and we all know employers and top
level leaders have an expectation
dare I say demand maybe that their top
people understand these Technologies and
are able to leverage their full
capabilities all right and maybe one of
the reasons why you find ourselves with
us here today and considering this
program these two these new technology
tools they really allow us to mine this
unstructured data in very productive
ways and that's another fundamental
Cornerstone in this course I think
so it impacts every business
this course is going to show you a
number of examples okay that come from
organizations that have successfully
applied AI machine learning Technologies
to develop new sales and marketing
strategies is one example
we'll be looking at the work that's been
done by modern marketing firms to
develop personalized recommendation
engines
um explore other marketing strategies
that are informed by kind of large
transactional and analytical databases
that are really informed by large pools
of customer behavior that kind of
augment our data pools
and you'll be looking at large Financial
applications like think things like
mid-stream identification of patterns of
con customer consumer behavior that
suggests fraudulent activity maybe for
companies that are processing e-commerce
platforms or transactions I should say
this enables the potential for
intervention right to take steps that
assure the security of transactional
security for transactions that might
initially appear suspicious
um let's see what else do we be covering
we we call in our incredible faculty
that are associated here with Wharton's
people analytics initiative
their conference actually was hosted
right here in person in Philadelphia two
weeks ago
um
to examine how Ai and machine learning
can be used to successfully navigate
the kind of task of all tasks informing
your decisions on hiring your decisions
on promotion your decisions on
Performance Management
I'm actually in the Performance
Management cycle myself right and we all
know the more direct reports you have
the better you want to be at this AI can
play a strong role here
but let's remember to the ethical
considerations when it comes to the
management of people right that critical
aspect is not overlooked here and it is
one that I hope all of us think really
seriously
one um you know one thing I was thinking
about Stuart I think you had done an
interview some time ago with some uh
fintech firm called zest money yep
that's true
um we had a webinar with the founder of
zest money and one of the interesting
things that she explained was that uh
their firm could not exist without AI
because it's one of the many fintech
firms micro credit firms that makes
instant decisions for a consumer at the
point of sale
you are considering to make making a
purchase and you want to finance it
through zest money uh when you tell best
money this is the item I'm going to buy
this is how much I want to spend
they can access with your permission all
of your
not only financial records but other
records about your behavior as a
consumer and then make an instant
decision about whether to extend a
credit
but how much so
that can't be done by humans
underwriting credit by humans was a
process that would take
days sometimes weeks when people would
send in applications for things like a
credit card
with the application of AI
that
amount of data and the number of sources
of data that
decision engine can access much much
broader than any human being could
access and it's done almost
instantaneously so they can make better
decisions about
credit worthiness of consumers
that than any human being could
and with better
breadth and depth so that they can
consider things that might otherwise be
left out of a credit decision that might
otherwise not be considered yet the
credit you need
sure thanks for bringing some color to
that because it brings us up to that
question again of ethicality
like
how does your model
function in a way that's inclusive right
what does it take into account to
determine credit worthiness
how do we determine credit risk or maybe
a lack thereof so if we think about more
broadly like G20 countries even here in
the United States
people that lack psycho scores as an
example here they can't qualify for
loans
and if you can't qualify for loans this
works to sort of exacerbate the
inequality that we systems that we see
here
the differences between the people that
have and the people that don't
and then can perpetuate itself generally
generationally right could we not use
these Technologies like Stuart was just
talking about via that interview with
that to think about what we can do to
leverage new forms
of assessing credit worthiness right
maybe not seen so much Through The Eyes
of these outdated Legacy systems and
applications
this is some of the things that you can
start to explore in your own mind and
also in the application of content
through this program so this kind of
brings us to this idea of a well-rounded
understanding of the field
the name of the screen you see in front
of you right now to prepare yourself for
this new decision-making Arena okay this
course helps individuals gain the kind
of sort of like tactile experience or
exposure to the terminology the
nomenclature as we would say that the
engineers and the data scientists use in
building and developing Ai and machine
learning projects in say your respective
company or organization this course
enables you to level set with an
understanding of these Technologies we
ask questions like what constitutes Big
Data what constitutes artificial
intelligence what is machine learning
and how is it conceived relative to one
other example like relative to company
size
what does it mean for say a small firm
and how they might pursue outsourced
Solutions on the open market what about
a big firm in their application
Development Group or teams
so if we bring it back full circle to
people management
legitimate concerns over HR applications
there are Myriad of corporate
organizational risks here right the
committee associated with the AI
algorithms have the unfortunate
potential of being just as biased as
individuals when it comes to things like
hiring things like promotion performance
assessment this course is going to
compel you to kind of take a big step
back to realize ways in which AI
applications can Implement and spread
bias in an undetected way or it can be
in some circumstances less than
transparent and processes that utilize
various data points to inform that
algorithm to make a particular
recommendation okay these are critically
important issues for General management
and this is perhaps even more critical
for those working in if you find
yourself in a non-profit or government
sectors okay
um this may be a good time Stuart to
Pivot to our poll
all right and I'll be glad to do that
we'll be talking about
your level of experience
in the end
I'm sorry before we do that what's
stopping you uh you're here
for this uh webinar because you're
interested in Ai and you're considering
this type of an educational program to
get as Eric said level set on
understanding what it is and what it can
do for your organization what has
stopped you
up till now from becoming part of a
program like this
I'll give you just another about 10
seconds
you can pick more than one of these
issues
we'll close this poll in five
four three
two one hit that submit button
so as you can see the the the first two
of these are the ones on most people's
mind here today I'm finding a program
that is comprehensive and finding a
program that gives you practical
examples to work from
so we'll talk a bit about how that
um
gets addressed in this program move on
Eric did you want to take over or shall
I go ahead with this
um well maybe I'll just offer a couple
quick notes on
um
practical exposure yeah given the
popularity of that response
um
one of the things that is different
I think for Wharton programming is that
we don't focus on curricula or
development of their
of what you might refer to as things
that are settled
I remember Don used to call it settled
science
for example I'm
not recommending you enroll in this
program Because by the end you're going
to start coding an R okay this is not
necessarily what you might see in a
continuing studies boot camp so to speak
we at Wharton online draw on the top
academic Minds in the world in this
field of study to analyze to research
topics that are unsettled
yeah and as we might have said we're
sort of like setting a table
where on one side we have the top Minds
from Academia that we provide here at
the Wharton School and on the other side
we have all of you top Minds from
business okay my expectation is that
when we bring all of you together we
start to find new bodies of knowledge we
find new conclusions about things that
are unsettled and we take that knowledge
with us into our work environments and
we apply them
we find greater success okay
um we're at the of the opinion I think
here at the Wharton School that new
knowledge is cultivated by this
bringing together of both sides of that
table okay
I think that's really exciting
personally
um and I think that's one of the big
draws of programs like this and why this
partnership with simply learns allowed
us to do something more Dynamic okay
faculty bring research from the
organizations they are actively
Consulting with and they use that data
to conduct their research and we hope
that you bring into that work and you
inform it with your own practical
knowledge your own context we've got a
global audience here that's fantastic
think about the people that you'll get
to interact with in this program
and you'll gain the ability to kind of
test hypotheses together and this
combination of intellectual power covers
a variety of cases across a diverse set
of Industries in this curriculum and it
starts to manifest itself in live
discussions and interactions
um
so when I think about where we got to
that idea of practical exposure Stuart I
think this program is really a
differentiator in that thing
oh Stuart you're muted
apologies
um
thank you for that uh the uh the
distinction you made between a program
that teaches AI engineering
versus a program of this type which
teaches you how to understand AI in the
context of using it for your
organization's decision making that's no
very important distinction and so
the as you said the Practical experience
is going to be drawn from the examples
the uh
faculty will bring from their actual
work with
people out in the industry so yeah we
talked about actually sorry this
reminded me of something else I think is
relevant here I I spent a number of
years overseeing an entire master's
degree in Business analytics
um and one of the things we would talk
about often was
the practical skills that you gain are
really important
but they're also dated
this is an industry that is changing so
dynamically and so fast consider the
idea that this is a program that is
going to give you decision-making power
right something that'll still be
relevant when we've moved vintage those
are skills that you keep with you right
those are skills that you continue to
take forward even if the industry
continues to change and I think that's
another important piece of this that
shouldn't get lost as we think about the
actual platforms that we talk about yeah
here's a piece of perspective on the
development of AI
how slowly and quickly it is gone in
both both dimensions
um
the Turing test was posited by Alan
Turing
back in the 1940s 1950s where he said
that
you would be able to call a system
artificially intelligent if you could
have a conversation with it and not know
that you were talking to a machine
uh in the 1960s some researchers
attempted to do this with a program
called Eliza which mimicked a
psychoanalyst you could ask it questions
and then that would respond to you and
the question was whether you could tell
you were talking to a machine or an
actual psychoanalyst on the other end of
a teletype
um didn't work all that well to pass the
Turing test over the years this type of
thing has happened and developed chat
Bots
now the the latest thing that we're
hearing about of course is chat gbt and
equivalent which
a lot of ways do reach the level of
passing the Turing test where you can
ask it to create something for you
that seems like it was written like by a
human being or you can interact with you
ways that you would expect a human being
to interact with you so
um Concepts in AI have been around for
decades implementations of those
Concepts keep changing year by year and
sometimes
change comes at a very rapid Pace but
understanding the fundamental concepts
and
being able to adapt them to whatever new
technology emerges is
kind of skill set we're trying to build
here with this program
and it's a three-month program it's
fully online I participate in online
discussions and you access other
materials on the online platform so you
don't have to
travel anywhere you don't have to
acquire any other specialized software
it's through any device that you have
that has a web browser on it and you can
other than the scheduled
meetings with the faculty members
classes with the faculty members you can
access the other material anytime
that you have time in your in your
schedule
um
at the end of it you receive the
certification that you've completed the
program you've done a lot of real world
business case study discussions with the
faculty members who have taken you
through these examples and
discussed with you in depth enough so
that you have a good understanding grasp
of what their implications are for your
business
and all done through live online master
classes with Wharton professors along
with the other materials
uh
you touched on an earlier Eric but if
you could again talk about why Wharton's
really one of the best places
in the world for this type of inquiry
I um
is that a
conference in Orlando Florida
back in October
um
all for say chro type participants
and over and over again I had people
come up to me Steward and they kept
saying oh I'm such a fan of this
professor or I'm so oh I'm such a fan of
that professor
and it happened over and over again and
it was never the same name twice
it was fascinating to me
um and a good reminder of the
research and intellectual power that
this institution brings to Bear is
arguably the best business school in the
world
um the interesting thing that I think
differentiates Wharton online in this
program would simply learn from other
Executive Education programs that are
out there in the marketplace is that we
really only use standing faculty
um these are tenured full faculty
members that are well established in
their fields in many cases the leader in
a particular area and that is absolutely
true in this program too
um we have actually eight different
Wharton faculty that bring their
um intellectual property and their
expertise into this program
um we're talking across various
departments too operations
Finance Management
marketing legal studies and business
ethics who also happen to be one of the
world's Authority on black blockchain
cryptocurrency distributed ledgers
um
it's a really impressive group and I
think it's important to for folks to
know that differentiation right you're
not getting into a program where the
videos were facilitated by a very
capable but in often cases an adjunct an
industry person
um those pieces of information can
definitely be valuable but when you're
talking about a series of eight
different Wharton faculty full faculty
members bringing to Bear their
respective areas of expertise I think
you've got a pretty Dynamic experience
set for yourself
thank you can muted myself
so this program is intended
for people who are not
necessarily technologists but people who
are at senior levels in their
organizations or who interact with
senior levels of organizations for
example as consultants and we talk about
uh ideal candidates for this program
um did you have some comments on on that
Eric or shall I
go through this
I think we're talking about c-suite
Executives certainly can benefit senior
Executives below the c-suite who want to
influence the direction of their uh
business or organization Business
Leaders and management
um who need to make strategic decisions
around AI if you're at that level and
you need to be able to apply AI to a
problem or a strategic area in your
organization
need to have this understanding and then
people who want to just become more
proficient and more knowledgeable about
the area
their own rights so that they can
kind of
build out their own toolkit
or general Management in understanding
the technology impact for their
organizations
have I got that about right
I think you do Stuart I you know one of
the words we often fall back to is
translation
where you have the requisite knowledge
where you can speak the languages of
both the engineers on one side and the
c-suite executive on the other right and
you can bring those things together
where you start to have like capital T
team right and your level setting common
language that everybody understands to
actually get the bright Business
Solution
there's a a kind of a certain kind of
dysfunction that happens when that's
absent where
as the management side you have to take
completely on face value whatever the
technology side tells you
because you don't have the
infrastructure or the understanding of
how that works to be able to evaluate
what they're telling you and this
program is
a way to combat that that dysfunction to
give you the ability to say okay I
understand what you're saying and will
that really work or is that really how
long it's going to take or are is that
really the best approach because you'll
have the the understanding of the
context that they're using and you won't
just have to take their word for it so
that's a great aspect of this program
um
we're going to run our next poll here
and this is just to give an idea of
where you are in your career right now
doesn't quite match the uh the widget
here but yes
you answer according to what the widget
is telling you and we're interested to
know if you're a student or if you're a
senior level in your organization
somewhere in between
and I will close this poll in five
seconds
four
three two one
and so the vast majority of our audience
today are
people who are senior in their
organizations
or whom I think this program has the
most benefit
to move on and talk about
how this program
prepares you for
uh
the
goals that we've described throughout
this this webinar
you begin it's built in a module a
module basis and it takes you through
the different modules so that you have
from each one the basis to do a more
in-depth and
valuable discussion excellent and that
foundation's a big data Ai and machine
learning our level setting
or understanding what the terms mean
what the Technologies are in a practical
sense get an understanding
what they do
how they interrelate
because all three have distinctions all
three have interdependencies and
this first module helps you with that
then you'll look into applications
within the marketing world
spend some time on that with the
marketing faculty
moving on then into the finance domain
and
it gets into some more interesting
um
Technical and unethical issues is as
Eric discussed
and finally into Resource Management
which again touches on things that have
to do with
fighting bias looking for a deeper
understanding of people's behavior so
that you can make
better decisions about
your human resource management
and then finally into the economics and
government space and looking at the
issues of Ethics the issues of how
have to control this technology in order
to make sure it's your servant
I'm your master and also
how to deal with external factors that
people will pose in terms of
requiring you to manage this technology
and government in a way that
meets
regulatory requirements that meet
Business Association requirements
insurance company requirements all the
other types of
external organizations that apply not
least of which include the public in
your consumer base so
at the end of this
you will receive your certificate and
along the way you can take these master
classes with the Wharton faculty which
are so valuable within this program
recommend that you arrange your schedule
to be able to take those classes they do
not we call them electives but they do
not cost anything additional they're
included in the program
and they help you build to a successful
conclusion the certificate
a test
station by Wharton that you have
successfully completed the program that
you've absorbed the concepts and that
you have this new set of skills and
understanding
to be able to
navigate the world
AI in business
as Eric mentioned
The Faculty members involved in this
program are really a Powerhouse you know
these people much better than I do Eric
um mention anything about this faculty
you know Stuart we could have had our
own session just on these eight or just
on one at a time
um
I would just offer having sat in the
classroom with with several of these
folks
it's more than just being an expert in
the field it's knowing how to engage a
room whether that's a virtual
environment or it's in a physical space
these folks know how to engage an
audience they know how to Captivate your
attention and they know how to
facilitate really robust dialogue and I
would say that it is true for all eight
of these individuals which is a rarity
when it comes to programs like this that
have multiple courses baked into an
entire sequence
um so I I just kind of offer that if
you've ever heard of any of these
individuals before or you may have even
taken a singular module
um that they've produced elsewhere
um
I think you probably have seen and
witnessed what I just offered
thank you
um
So based on what you've heard so far
from from Eric and myself
I'm curious to know are you interested
in potentially taking this program
this is not
a hard and fast decision but it
we'd like to find out your level of
Interest
since it's a yes or no question we'll
just leave this open for another 10
seconds
close in five
or
free
to
one hit the submit button
it's roughly two-thirds
of our audience today are interested
this is a good time for me to share with
you the
steps
to
achieve that
extremely straightforward again as we're
the delivery partner you email to us at
ask us at simplylearn.net
and we review your prerequisites a
little bit about your
work history and level of
that you're at in your organization
again
we're not testing you on
technology knowledge because that's not
a prerequisite for this course
um
we'll send you your admission offer and
let you know
the next cohort actually starts in two
days
pricing here is given for
North America and for India you'll be
able to look at local pricing in your
country by going to our
uh home page for the program on our
website and what I'm going to do now is
put that link into
the
chat
excuse me as I copy that over
and
that will give you local pricing you can
also ask that question of
the learning consultant by reaching out
to ask us at simplylearn.net and that
email is also in the chat with you
and
again this can we have options for
financing over time
we also remind you to ask your employer
about tuition reimbursement if you have
that benefit at work that's a great
thing
we're mentioning a bonus discount offer
attending this webinar and I hesitate to
tell you what it is uh in this forum
because we're looking at a worldwide
audience for the US it's denominated in
dollars for the
rest of the world I think it's nominated
in percentages so do ask
um the learning consultant but we will
also be sending you a follow-up email
that contains uh the amount for this
offer and this is a discount off of
these fees if you begin the uh the 20th
April cohort
um we ask you to do that quickly because
in this type of a program
the cohorts have to be limited in size
because of the level of interaction
between the faculty and
participants
um we don't want to get to so many
people this is not as Eric alluded to
before the history of online courses
started off with massively open online
courses this is not one of those this is
a more
intimate
colloquial or
um
discussion type of arrangement a seminar
of a type of arrangement so that you
need to be able to interact with the
instructor and instructor with you a
faculty member has to be able to devote
a sufficient attention to people and
that limits the number of people can
take in any given cohort cohorts do
start regularly so if you are not able
to start the 20th of April you'll be
able to find out from our learning
consultant when the next one is
again do reach out to us and
find out the answers to those particular
questions and then I'm going to ask you
for those of you who said you are
interested
at what point would you like to start
are you interested potentially in that
cohort starting this week or are you
looking further down the road
I will leave this one open for about 15
seconds more
numbers have stopped changing much so
I'm going to go ahead and close it in
three
to
one hit the submit button
I will share the result
and about 40 percent of you are either
interested in starting
on the April 20th cohort start or uh
sometime soon thereafter
and for the people looking further down
the road do reach out to us and ask us
at simplywin.net we'll keep you informed
about
future cohorts and we'll also be able to
answer other questions you may have and
speaking of questions
this is a time for us to
take some of your questions that may be
in the Q a here
so
because essay so Bob asks does SAS have
analogous procedures to Python and R
platforms
it's a pretty interesting technical
question I'm not sure that that's when
we can answer for you your
but that is something you have a comment
on that Eric
this is where I defer to the actual Ai
and machine learning experts yeah
um moreover this is this is getting into
the type of
well
this is again something you would ask
some of the faculty members and we can
you can ask at ask us at simplylearn.net
to get referrals for that uh do you have
a practical example from your
certificate
that you can share showing a problem
which AI solved so this would be a
question Eric if you know of
the type of problem or case study that
has been presented
so
um it depends on which course you're
going to be into right because with with
the variety it's going to be dictated by
those fields
um I also know that we are on a recorded
session and the faculty are in the
school is protective of IP
so when you get in to see those specific
examples
um you'll know them when they're in
front of you that I can promise you
um you I'm sorry for my cat just walking
in front of my face
um
so one of the interesting things about
this is that you
I I spoke with you about zest money
because that's on the record from the
the
founder of zest money but that's the
type of case study that
you would be looking at in terms of what
was the challenge
what was the application of AI and how
would you approach a similar challenge
in your organization so that
I would take the zest money example as a
kind of representative the type of
discussion you'll have
um
but it won't be this money
thank you for this opportunity which
programming language should we study
and that's a fascinating question
because in this program you're not going
to be learning programming you're not
going to be doing programming
um but if you are interested in
programming languages
there are a number of
programs that simply learn offers that
go into the technology guts and
Engineering side of AI
and look at some of those
generally when you're looking into
Eric referred to R and python are
important
languages for data science but then
there are a whole host of other tools
and platforms that build upon that the
use in building machine learning and
AI Solutions
it's like tensorflowing so
um
like to learn more about the topics what
will I learn specifically
how
then how this program will be okay
um so I think we
've we've spoken about that but you can
go back together and talk about the that
question actually sorry Stuart that
question actually came through right as
you were getting into
so the timing was actually probably
perfect because you went right into that
section at that moment
okay
good um yeah you're you're going to
specifically look at examples in
marketing in finance in HR you're going
to go deeper into the ethics and
governance
so it's
that I think answers to that question
I'm going to look into the chat just
quickly to see
will you have access to alumni a good
question for you
I will uh participants in the program
will they be able to interact with
people in the Alumni network
this program I mean certainly connects
you to the people that you'll share the
cohort with I think we work with simply
learn too to bring the broader community
of Learners that have engaged in this
program together
um but this is not a credit bearing
program for say a student that's
matriculating toward a degree
so when we talk about our alumni
networks those are for people that
formally enrolled came here right and
went through the entire process yeah
um
Perez in the chat how large are the
classes generally
um cohorts range up to about 30
participants because as I described
earlier
you can't devote sufficient attention in
a discussion of this type
uh more than that without shortchanging
some of the people allowing them to get
their their interaction with the faculty
members so those are that's about the
limit
um
do individuals need programming
experience no this is not going to be
focusing on programming this is focusing
on uh business knowledge and business
applications
um
again there are other options for people
in the audience here today if you're
considering an AI engineering program we
point you to some of those but
for the particular target audience of
this program which is people in
management people who are responsible
for business strategy
this program is focused on those aspects
I think that's all the questions we have
currently so I'm going to move on to the
final question I have for the audience
I want to thank Eric for being
very patient
second
all right
so this question is do you need
assistance to enroll
um if you answered yes to this question
we'll make sure to reach out to you and
in addition
um if you are interested in receiving
um for some reason the proof of
attendance for this webinar will be able
to send you one of those if you answer
yes to this question so
and we'll just leave this open for five
seconds longer
or be
two one
so for those of you who answered yes we
will be contacting you for those who
answered no
you'll receive a follow-up email from us
with the link to this recording
information on the bonus offer and
you can always reach out to us at ask us
at simplylearn.net the QR code also
takes you to the
program page on our website
this is when I would like to again
formally thank
Eric for being here with us today and
being very generous with his time and
knowledge
and taking us through the
the origins and purpose of this program
you were my pleasure and I want to say
thanks to you for hosting and for
everybody dedicating some of their day
to joining us yeah really appreciate it
everybody we do want to thank you all in
the audience uh everyone worldwide
from
they said the four corners of the globe
and we will hope that we can see you in
the uh Wharton online and simply learn
learning community
so we look forward to our future
interactions thanks again for being here
that concludes our webinar for today
take care everybody
thank you